this is something that technology cannot
solve on its own like you have to have
much more empathy and compassion and
insight
into the human psychology really
understanding the emotional barriers
that go into people like having
difficulty to change your behavior and
what are the mechanics that you can
build into that
thank you for joining me on 20 minute
leaders how are you
i'm great how are you happy holidays
happy holidays to you too
i'm so excited to talk about user
experience with you like i mentioned we
we
i didn't get to talk to it about it
nearly enough in the in the 300 episodes
we've had
them and i'm super excited to dig deep
into the importance of user experience
and in everything we do both in
in tech and startups but in daily life
as well and and before we get started i
have to say
your your experience with ux is
remarkable
i think that i i saw about a dozen
different organizations that you've made
an impact on in the
world of ux all the way from a startup
like zoox to a google
to verily and now a hero so tell me a
little bit about your journey how do you
even get started with
with dealing with user experience
yeah that's a great question it goes uh
quite a few years back
actually the story starts back in israel
where i was born and raised
and when i after i finished my army
service i actually joined the company
and that's kind of like was my entry to
the tech industry uh and actually john
is a qa
ah and i started working there and back
in the days it was about what
uh probably about 15 to 20 years ago
ux in israel uh like wasn't an industry
like there were like there was no
education around it there were not
a lot of companies that was doing that
it was just like early on where
mostly engineers were just like building
the uis based on
like what they thought were uh was the
right thing to do and
and actually remember those early days
where i was doing qa and i was testing
the functionality of the product but i
kind of started also asking just like
intuitively all these questions
why you know why do we have all these
menu items like why does the workflow
work like this
uh and i started just like within the
culture of that company we started
talking about this idea of like
usability and ui
super early on uh so that's kind of like
was the early early seats then i
actually
i went to uh a school uh and i started
computer
computer science and business management
however halfway through my degree i
actually decided that computer science
is not what i want to continue doing i
didn't see myself just like you know
exceeding and coding really wanted to
see how i can bring more
people focused creative uh doing into
kind of like what i do
in my career so i paused i started
exploring kind of like what i want to do
next and i ended up
actually uh going on a multiple route of
uh psychology and communication
is one bachelor degree and i also
continued my
business management as a parallel path
and i continued with these two
bachelor degrees um and i really enjoyed
it but then kind of like as i was
studying i was like okay what am i going
to do with all these degrees like what
you know what does that translate to
and while i was in school i kind of like
went back to this like oh you know there
was this like ux thing
that i kind of like started talking back
then and been super interesting
and it made me feel like this could be
something that i'm good at that really
brings together this like
you know the cognitive psychology
with technology so honestly what i ended
up doing
is one evening i just opened google and
i just searched for all the ux companies
in israel and i just applied to all of
them i wrote a cover letter explaining
why i think
bring value to that company and i and i
just like throw it out there
um a couple of companies got back to me
i started an interview process
uh and luckily enough i landed in two
which was kind of like one of the top
design agencies in israel
uh and that was actually my entry point
so you know you go into an agency it's
just like
all about like having a lot of ux people
there uh i worked there for almost four
years and i
think i built a lot of just like
hands-on experience and
understanding working with like
thousands and dozens of clients across
so many different platforms you know
mobile and web and tv and across like
media and finance and gaming and and
that gave me like so much
experience with that um so yeah so
that's kind of like how i started
uh from there i actually joined module
uh
which was founded by dove mulan one of
kind of like the top
uh entrepreneurs in israel uh
and during my uh work at modu actually
nine months into my work there i was
approached by google
uh and the funny story was that at the
time like like i don't want to pursue
that like i was very happy
at modu and then a friend of mine said
like what
like what are you saying are you crazy
you know get started
go through the hiring process you can
always say no at the end
um so i started uh and it ended up being
a really long process uh it was about
seven months of hiring process because
it was the first ux higher
israel so i had like 14 interview
across around
yeah but during that time seven months
of interviewing you start getting
excited about the opportunity
and it feels kind of like this
psychological
connection and um i ended up getting
higher
and this is how i started my google
journey which really kind of like
accompanied me over the
the following decade i spent six and a
half years with google
i moved to the us through google
i worked at verily uh and now on the
table
unbelievable yeah i i i have to give the
analogy i went
i i never wanted to be a pilot my father
was a pilot and
when it came down to going to do you
know the army
testing which we do in israel and of
course you know
we i said okay you know they're inviting
me to try i knew that i didn't want to
be a paladin
but all my friends said well michael you
have to try like you know it's a like
you have to at least get
you have to see if you can make it and
you i remember they sent me to the geek
which was one of the worst
weeks of my life and i'm traumatized but
until today because it was so difficult
by the end of what when i was accepted
it was so hard to say no even though i
didn't want to be a pilot i felt like i
just had to do it because i got through
it
as if it doesn't for myself but i have
to give that analogy and and you i think
you said it wrong you said that you know
they hired me no you said you said yes
that's what i think it's it more comes
down to for what i'm gathering from the
story
break it down for me user experience you
mentioned the psychology communication
computer science this integration of of
understanding
user behavior break it down for me what
is user experience and why is it so
fascinating to you
yeah ah that's a good question uh at the
end of the day
you know it's kind of like it's stopping
uh with understanding you know
why are we doing you know you start with
the why i think that's kind of like one
title
uh you know commonly associated with uh
simon sinek i think i
i kind of like very much relate to that
uh it's really like starting to think
about what you're doing
and what you're building by truly
understanding what people need
what other pain points what other mental
models behavior and this is where the
psychology really kind of like going
deep into
understanding what is the problem that
you're trying to solve what are the
common barriers what are the current
pain points
uh and really starting from their needs
and goals doing that analysis really
understanding the people and the
audiences that you are trying to
uh to solve a problem for and and go
from there
uh so it's not about starting with the
technology and everything we can do
because the technology can do x and can
do y
uh which is what we call a tech driven
approach it's it's a user-centered
approach
like let's understand what do people
even need and then see what is the best
way to do that and again it doesn't mean
that we necessarily need to do
all the fancy stuff uh we really need to
hone in on what are the key
needs um i think a good example for that
and for the kind of like how it
um how it manifests itself i actually
think the last couple of years working
in healthcare
is a really great example mikhail new
background new environment
same user experience same question
talking about health care a little bit
from your experiences well
why is why is your experience with
healthcare an interesting example of the
importance of user experience
yeah i think it's a it's a really great
example of the difference
between technology diff uh um focused
approach and user-centered approach
because you know there's a lot of like
promising technologies and things that
we can do you know machine learning and
ai
and we can build all these like amazing
tools uh and do sophisticated things but
when you actually try to innovate within
healthcare
what you realize that oftentimes you
know when you try to build tools for
like health systems physicians you know
the the secret and what would actually
get you to change uh and move the needle
is how well you can integrate into their
existing workflows
so if you start building all these like
amazing tools but they're actually a
separate tool that they need to log into
that they need to open that they need to
learn
that is a huge barrier for adoption and
oftentimes the innovation would come by
like
finding the ways that you can integrate
into their ehr and even if the ehl ux is
not great
this is where they're at and you need to
find the creative ways of integrating
yourself there and being
in it as part of their workflows and
seeing
how through their you can bring value to
them so
oftentimes it's not necessarily like all
the
amazing beautiful technology that we can
build independently
is really finding the way to tapping
yourselves into their busy schedule and
really understanding that they have like
five minutes a day to take a look at
these things and if you want to squeeze
yourself
within their daily routine it's not
going to be
with building a whole other tool that's
outside of their
um kind of like habits i think that's
that's a fascinating example because
because you know it's the
entrepreneurial mindset of any
especially young entrepreneurs saying
okay we have this idea we want to make
it all around beautiful products with
our own login screen and our own user
experience
and we're so excited to to show this
all-encompassing product when
you know if we forget a little bit about
the customer that again
needs to use the product and what their
behavior is and how are we fitting into
their behavior then we might have this
crazy misalignment
where nobody can even use your product
because you're not aligning to
what what they actually need why isn't
the
engineer in the room or the product
manager in the room
enough to understand this why is there a
specific
role called user experience in
why is that why is there this function
within a company why isn't it enough
that
you know engineers just think critically
about their customers and just adapt to
that
yeah it's a great question and i would
tell by saying that again like the
the culture that i've been raised on and
i truly believe in is it's it's not like
the the ux person
is the only one that solves all the
problems i think it's like
continuously collaborative process where
we work together engineering and product
nux bringing all the considerations
together thinking through
user problems i think it's important
across the organization whether you're
product manager engineer
uh regulatory person to have a shared
understanding of what are we building
why are we building who are our users so
i think this is actually something that
culturally need to be
shelled i think in terms of like when
when do we need it
like why do we need a dedicated uh role
i think it's just
a a full-time job to do that work well
and at the end of the day it's just like
any role like why do we need pgms i
can't a pmb pgm
in some scenarios yes like people can
build that skill set
i think it's just like at the end of the
day like you have a limited bandwidth
there's work to be done and if you want
to do it well
you need dedicated resources that can
have the bandwidth to do it so if a pm
needs to like opinion
why like why are not them the engineers
as well because if they need
they're gonna need to spend half the day
on it so they don't have the time to
collect the business requirements and do
like landscape analysis and talk to
customers so
i don't think it's uh it's necessarily
like people that have like a
like a specific superpower that others
cannot learn or gain it's more about how
do you build a healthy organization
where you put your
resources on the key things that have to
be you know
super thoughtful go deep and truly
understand
so we do build the best product
i think that's fascinating and one of
the things that i'm always asking myself
in the context of user experiences
you know the way that i think about user
experience to some degree is
thinking okay we have this this
intuition about how we should approach
solving the problem for our users
and user experience professionals can
help us
navigate that intuition into
practicality and research
data data-driven analysis of what
actually do our users need and how do
actually can we use our intuition to
navigate there and one of the things
that i'm always
asking myself is how do you even know
that there's a problem
right how do you know that you know if i
have a hundred functions within a
company
and i'm guessing you know within google
and verily in those different companies
you've been a part of there were many
many aspects where user experience was
important
how can you know the ceo the engineer or
the product
manager even pinpoint the parts where a
user experienced professional
may be of use
yeah well uh
i think kind of like as you said it
starts with like research and really
understanding what we're trying to solve
so i think every
uh entrepreneur every ceo every product
manager uh
they usually start their uh initiative
by observing a problem by observing
you know an unsolved need or a need that
is not being solved well enough
and then in order for you to talk
differently so
you sometimes if you went through this
personally you already have some
insights around you know what you
experience as being like the key
barriers
or the key gaps if you're trying now to
kind of say okay how do we build a
skilled
product out of that you need to do kind
of like go deeper and see how much is
your experience actually applicable more
broadly you want to understand what are
the type of audience that affected that
and there's a lot of
research that needs to go into
understanding kind of like more deeply
what does that entail so again like
well the problems coming from what are
people's expectations
uh as well as you know in an ongoing way
as you develop
the product whether it's based on your
intuitions and kind of like your ideas
you want to validate that and again you
need people that can go and
thoughtfully do that so you know there's
like different approaches oftentimes
people just think that they can go to
people and say
would you like this feature would you
find this feature useful which again
kind of like for a lot of people it
feels like intuitive to do but that
actually doesn't generate
and like any viable results called
whenever you ask
anybody if they want this or that they
will usually say yes because why not if
we can get more
a lot more that goes into it because
what you end up seeing that people use
maybe 10
of the features that you offer them
because at the end of the day when they
actually use their product and those
trade-offs whether in terms of like
complexity and time and
all those things they're not going to
use it so you do need to have
particular skills to do the research
well so so you gain the right
insight that you can rely on also you
really want to have kind of like
a holistic approach to look at
qualitative data and quantitative data
and again like doing all of that you
know time
required expertise also how do you
design things well like how the whole
there's a whole like uh investment now
and this is an area that i'm also like
super excited about is like this whole
idea of
behavior change and i think that's
another angle that to me represent
how important ux is because we see it
again in healthcare but
everywhere you can build all the most
amazing devices
whether it's you know wearables or like
all the crazy stuff that we see that is
amazing but between having an amazing
device and getting people to use it
every day
there is a big big gap right this is why
we see that like
obesity is like more prevalent than ever
and like changing behavior with people
is so so high
i think this is well this is something
that technology cannot solve on its own
like you have to have much more empathy
and
compassion and insight into the human
psychology really understanding
the emotional barriers that go into
people like
having difficulty to change our behavior
and what are the mechanics that you can
build into that
so to me that's another area where i see
healthcare like ux is critical to really
change people's behavior at scale
still an unresolved problem uh
ux is critical and i think this is where
i see a lot of the value that comes
by by really going deep on these areas
it's fascinating beyond uh beyond belief
i just read a really interesting article
by my one of my former bosses
kristen berman from the irrational lab
one of the
realities projects and which she was
talking about you know the vaccine
like thinking about the kobe 19 vaccine
and the user experience
behind that whole distribution and now
we're in this
this situation where we need like 75
percent of the world
to take this shot you know voluntarily
in order to resolve this pandemic and
it's fascinating i think thinking of
behavioral economics and how
and you know you see prime ministers
going on live television doing
themselves like that's a part of user
experience journey
right and i'm i'm really wondering
sometimes how much thought really is put
into these
critical critical things and i i have a
hunch that it's not enough
and we need more people like you to to
help
these these different things but that's
fascinating we don't have much time
but give me a few key insight nuggets
for
the young entrepreneur of how to
approach solving user experience
issues or or or intuitions as they
build their company whether it's for b2b
or b2c doesn't really matter
yeah that could be a topic for for an
entire conversation i think i
i would go back to kind of like where i
started well it starts with why
and i think this is also you know when i
interview ux people when i look for ux
people i start with like looking at the
critical thinking and the problem
solving skills before the
visual aesthetic and the ability to
design a screen well you really want
to have people asking why really
understanding like why are we doing that
why are we doing it this way can we
simplify it like
really keeping keep asking this why and
it's it's it's pretty interesting i have
two toddlers and i think those behaviors
you know
they ask why like 10 times on everything
they go to but why but why but why but
why
and it you know as a parent you know it
can sometimes be challenging but i think
that's the right
mindset and i think over time along the
way we start asking those deep why's but
i think that those
why's and going like three wise in you
know the first principle approach
really understanding why we need a
certain things and how can we do it
better i think this is where innovation
starts from
uh so that would be kind of like my my
top
uh uh advice in terms of the mindset
because i think it starts with a mindset
and the more you ask those why i think
this is where you start kind of like
thinking about things differently um the
other thing i would say
is what i think like personal experience
uh
is many times kind of provides good
intuition as to where we need to go
we do need to remind ourselves like you
are not the user in most cases
so we need to we need to make sure that
we're not making two strong assumptions
based on our own experience and take the
time to truly try and understand
the audience that we are targeting and
where are they coming from and what are
their challenges and making sure that we
have the empathy
uh and we really incorporate that into
how we approach the product and we
validate and we learn because things are
changing
all the time so um yeah i think that
that that's just uh inspiring so thank
you nicole for that
three words that you would use to
describe yourself and my favorite
question
okay so uh three words probably gonna
i'm gonna cheat a little bit because i'm
gonna use the two words for each one
uh but uh you know we can assume there's
a hyphen there so uh theoretically
speaking it's one
i think one thing about myself that um
characterizes me i think in everything
that i do and also my career is just
like people focused
i think it all starts with the people
hiring the right people building the
right relationships
uh being really people focusing kind of
like what people need how you can you
know grow them how do we work with them
as pills
that's gonna be one uh the second is
growth minded
i think constantly like i seek feedback
i see growth like i want to grow as an
individual i want to grow as a
professional i am a big believer in the
approach
of atomic habits you know get one
percent better every day
and so i i really do seek those avenues
of growth constantly
and the last thing i would say is um uh
daring greatly which is a concept that
has kind of like become
more popular with brene brown books
which i absolutely admire i think she is
she's brilliant and she
like the type of messages that that she
is trying to kind of like
disseminate are so important i want
vulnerability
and you know kind of like imperfection
uh but to me that's kind of like this
this idea of like being
in the arena you know fighting putting
in the blood and sweat and failing and
overcoming you know
obstacles until kind of like you ideally
succeed but really kind of like
not just critique and points kind of
like from the side on what's not working
but really being there and trying
and working out for like worthy outcomes
uh and do your best i just love that
mikhail thank you so so much this was
wonderful
i appreciate i appreciate your time so
much i know how busy you are
and all i can say is stay safe and stay
healthy and and thank you for the
amazing work that you're doing
thank you
you